when was the last time you cried when my
cat Morrissey died I got him when I was
one year clean by the time that cat died
I had children and I'm married and I
live in the countryside and I've been
flung around the cesspit fame when he
died a lot of things I carried went with
him couldn't poo on his own he couldn't
eat on his own I was sustaining him only
for myself because of my own inability
to let go of him I went from praying for
him to continue living to praying for
him to die peacefully that's a sign that
you're ready to let go of something or
someone I've arrived at a point of
wanting to be able to let go of
accepting that you can achieve more when
you let go of your will than you can
when you're trying to weaponize your
will there's a sadness in letting go
there's a sadness in knowing that you've
believed in things and that they're not
real the sort of relationships that are
expunged when my life is just about the
Fulfillment of what I want it's such a
short little Carousel now I feel like
what I believe in is personal Awakening
and participating where possible in The
Awakening of others